she did sorbets super nonsense like a
health care
dino adele and religions and single adress
adele
showed up and cheaper here a sim card
nat and george i make in flight bikini and
nappy end up kind of er peaks she's
not allowed to use your hair and shine
wedges  to sounds become fly on
another country
week is it cultural preparation and of
course all culture is approprié the
culture comes from co2 show so week already
two numbers 11
when beatles story time na
riding tolstoy and apollinaire of my own
imagination
arms proprio jumping from russia and
that's could be cause i already know
my poor brother quintin culture which
all culture must be with a tutor at the
curb and nonsense
or they have to encourage people to give
my want industry switch twice as expensive
the count de top we the grammy too
long  people app android webshop people
the king cove
here again logical anti-fog reason
why people kind shop to work day after
you anything like en de studio lec  ture
begins each know they have you come and
cultural dj mini de politics of the
japanese
de when institutions at when
ministry of government
no just push him sour here is fragile
i want crack i smoke crack for just
found
tie black save me too you enjoyed a
short segment of the michael no-show that is
sure to check out the full episode link
in the description or download the podcast
theory lesson in the podcast
[Music]
the